[Music]
on this Sunday night the far reach of
the Cova 19 crisis world numbers hit a
milestone while canada faces renewed
concerns over community outbreaks at the
game of whack-a-mole where these things
are gonna pop up the u.s. backtracks on
reopening we find ourselves careening
toward a catastrophic and unsustainable
situation as cases surged out of control
plus Joe Biden's ticket to the White
House
I want someone strong could the right
running mate make all the difference and
the loo lifts off the challenge to put a
bathroom on the moon
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with two grim global
milestones confirmed cases of Cova 19
has surpassed the 10 million mark while
the virus has now killed half a million
people we first became aware of it in
Wuhan China in December and in the seven
months since it has spread to nearly
every continent in the world only
Antarctica is kovat free North America
South America and Europe now account for
75% of the total confirmed cases 11
percent are in Asia of course it's the
u.s. that makes up the bulk of North
America's numbers it has more than 2.5
million cases and over a hundred and
twenty-five thousand deaths it's by far
the worst hit country in the world
Canada has recorded over a hundred
thousand cases and more than 8,500
deaths while the situation in Canada may
be stabilizing there are troubling signs
right across the country that we are not
out of the woods yet community outbreaks
of hundreds of people on alert and as
Heather York's West explains the steps
taken now could determine whether this
country faces a second wave and how bad
it gets
residents entering this downtown Calgary
condo high-rise are now greeted with a
warning from health officials the
building is home to the city's latest
outbreak of kovat 19 at least 45 people
have become sick three have been
hospitalized they think by surfaces like
elevators and everything like we've been
reassured that it can't flow through
vents or anything but yeah they're quite
confident it's like through elevator
touching the situation here helped push
Alberta's new case numbers Saturday to
highs not seen since mid-may across
Canada there have been outbreaks as well
at least 21 cases have been linked to an
outbreak at a nail salon in Kingston
Ontario in Vancouver patrons of a
popular strip club have been asked to
monitor for symptoms after several
people tested positive for kovat 19 it's
a game of whack-a-mole where these
things are gonna pop up and we just got
a crushed on s a as they pop up and
we've got to identify them as early
this infectious disease expert says
while outbreaks are not unexpected right
now staying on top of them is critical
and that's not something public health
units can do alone employers have a role
to play to ensure workplaces are safe
for both staff and patrons but to keep
numbers low individuals will have to
step up - citizens have their own
obligations that we need to do that
means washing our hands
that means maintaining two meters of
physical distancing and that means
putting on a mask when you go into an
indoor environment that's something that
will become more important the more
opportunities Canadians have to gather
in larger groups it's a great joy to be
open for the first time in months Sunday
residents in Montreal were able to
gather in places of worship with
restrictions in place maximum attendance
limits met not all were welcomed inside
I'm just a little sad that today I was
here at 8 and I could not enter actually
I was here at 7:30 and there was already
a lineup of people activities like
singing hems have made places of faith
super spreaders in the past moving far
worse a fleet will take vigilance and
caution in order to keep the virus at
bay
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
south of the border the Cova 19 crisis
is getting worse cases are spiking in
over 30 states including Florida which
some experts say could become the next
epicenter for infections as Jennifer
Johnson reports the Centers for Disease
Control warns numbers across the u.s.
could be up to 24 times higher than
what's being reported motorists lined up
for hours from Jacksonville to Miami
waiting to get tested for Koba 19 you
find out yesterday that his bus is
infected so he had to come today to get
tested some experts now fear Florida
will replace New York as the next
epicenter for the virus New York's
governor sounding the alarm as cases
reach staggering new levels in several
states if these states keep going up
we're going to have a national crisis
like we have never seen they said this
was the way to help the economy by
reopening is they've been the exact
opposite
Vice President Mike Pence travelled to
one of the country's newest hotspots
Texas Sunday speaking to a packed church
Pence and president Donald Trump are
facing an onslaught of criticism for not
insisting Americans wear masks to slow
down the spread of the virus we've made
it clear that we want to defer to
governor's we want to defer to local
officials @mr people should listen to
them but even some in the administration
are demanding precautions the window is
closing we have to act and people as
individuals have to act responsibly we
need to social distance many doctors say
the country needs to face the facts now
Kovac 19 by totals number of deaths is
the fourth largest catastrophe in
American history and is poised to become
totally the worst in American history if
we keep going at the at the great work
on Texas is among 12 states that have
stopped or rolled back reopening plans
on Monday restaurants have to scale back
capacity to 50% this is another setback
for a sector that has taken the brunt of
this not only in Texas but across the
entire nation a nation now facing a new
crisis from a pandemic that won't go
away Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington
US President Donald Trump is blasting
claims he knew that Russia reportedly
offered bounties for killing American
troops in Afghanistan the New York Times
says US intelligence officials concluded
months ago that Russia offered secret
awards to Taliban linked militants for
the deaths of US soldiers Trump tweeted
today nobody briefed or told me the Vice
President or chief of staff about the
so-called attacks on our troops in
Afghanistan by Russians former national
security advisor John Bolton who was
forced out by Trump last year says it's
remarkable the president's going out of
his way to say he hasn't heard anything
to me it looks like just another day at
the office in the Trump White House I've
never recalled a circumstance where the
President himself goes out of his way to
say he wasn't briefed on something the
time says Trump was told about the
intelligence in March and officials
developed a potential response
did not act Russia dismisses the report
as nonsense one man is dead in Kentucky
after a shooting at a protest of the
death of Brianna Taylor witnesses say a
man fired dozens of shots at a crowded
Park in Louisville last night where
protesters set up camp a second person
was hospitalized with
non-life-threatening injuries the park
which has now been cleared has been the
center of protests over police brutality
after the death of Taylor the first
responder was shot and killed in her
home in March after police executed a
no-knock warrant protesters have been
calling for the officers involved to be
charged one of them Detective Brett
Hankinson has been fired here at home
Vancouver's Transit Authority is
investigating a disturbing incident on a
bus that may be racially motivated a
black driver discovered what appeared to
be a noose shaped object and posted
pictures on Facebook he said he didn't
think anything of it until a passenger
said look driver someone left you a
noose perfect for hanging the driver who
was badly shaken said his heart sank and
Toronto Police are also investigating
after nurses were found at two
construction sites one of the
construction companies Ellis Dawn is
calling the incident disgraceful and
says it will do everything possible to
identify and prosecute anyone involved
the company says it has held talks with
employees to ask whoever did it to
confess China is lashing out at Canada
over what it calls megaphone diplomacy
Ottawa is urging Beijing to and what it
calls the arbitrary detention of Michel
khovrakh and Michel spa for the
diplomatic standoff is heating up with
Couric's wife urging action and 19
prominent Canadians calling for a
prisoner swap but Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau won't release Chinese telecom
executive man Wong's oh who was being
held in Vancouver so where do things go
from here
Michel Couture looks into that for us
tonight after a week that deepened our
diplomatic divide with China its embassy
in Ottawa took another shot at the
Trudeau government for alleged
irresponsible comments on the cases of
detained Canadians Michel coverage and
Michels pavor
claiming Canada is trying to exert
pressure on China through megaphone
diplomacy the statement also denounces
any link being made between the two
Michels and the extradition of Huawei
CFO Wang Wang Jo part of the problem
stems from these comments by the Chinese
foreign ministry spokesperson who was
referring to suggestions our justice
minister could stop mungs extradition
Jana dasa poppadom this is legal and
also helpful to solve the issues of the
two Canadians said the spokesperson
according to translators the embassy
statement Saturday refutes any link
between the two cases saying quote some
Canadian media deliberately reported
Michel kovorix wife's remarks as the
spokespersons statement this is
sometimes a problem in diplomacy
is that you hear what you want to hear
from the other side former diplomat
Colin Robertson says that's why Canada
should have sought clarification from
China
he believes the best approach is for the
government to continue rallying
international support from allies will
also feel China is flexing its muscle
keeping the pressure on as we are
through various intermediaries annoys
the Chinese but it does have effect and
that's why the Chinese saved please stop
this because they don't like it
Robertson also worries the calls for a
prisoner swap by 19 prominent Canadians
and kava rigs wife will signal
dissension to China however in an
interview on the West block with
Mercedes Stevenson Vina Najibullah says
she just wants the government to look at
other options what I know is we need
more leverage we need more space to
maneuver and hopefully the conversations
of this week have opened up a little bit
more space for that that is the hope
with this latest flare-up in the
diplomatic dispute could have further
painted Canada into a corner Mike
lacouture global news Ottawa its Pride
weekend in many places but efforts to
stop the spread of Cova 19 of four
celebrations to go digital to show you
can cancel events but can't cancel pride
especially on an important anniversary
Oh everybody welcome to Pride Toronto's
annual
transformed into an online affair with
musical performances and messages from
members of the LGBTQ community the pride
event showed support for the fight
against anti black racism it also
streamed to defund the police rally New
York's big parade went virtual with
Canadian actor Dan levy serving as one
of the grand marshals very wonderful
thousands still took to the city streets
for the queer liberation march against
police brutality the first pride march
was held in New York 50 years ago a year
after what became known as the Stonewall
riots on June 28th 1969 gay lesbian and
transgender patrons of the Stonewall Inn
fought back against police harassment
and brutality it's considered the
turning point for LGBTQ rights in the US
and around the world the bar is now part
of a National Monument
neither Cova 19 nor the rain could stop
about 200 people in Taiwan's capital
from putting on a Pride Parade
the event is normally held in October
but this year's celebration was bumped
up in a show of solidarity for all the
places that canceled pride events
because of pandemic restrictions Taiwan
is the first region in Asia to legalize
same-sex marriage more than 70 countries
around the world still have anti-gay
laws and in some places homosexuality is
punishable by death
coming up Biden's Choice why his pick
for running mate is so important in 2020
and hajj unhold the challenge facing
this tradition
the choice of a vice-presidential
candidate says a lot about who's running
for presidents it also sends a signal
about what the administration might look
like Joe Biden is promising to put a
woman and possibly a woman of color on
the ticket and if he wins the White
House his VP selection will be one of
the most important decisions in US
history
Eric Sorenson explains he would be the
oldest US president in history Joe Biden
views himself as a bridge to the next
generation which could make his
selection of a vice presidential running
mate a defining moment in US politics
for years to come I want someone strong
I want someone strong and someone who
can who is ready to be President on day
one Biden has promised to pick a woman
who would become the first female vice
president people are among the favorites
is senator Elizabeth Warren behind that
mask and Kamala Harris is now is time to
act another senator but also a woman of
color which has become an important
consideration as America confronts
racial injustice senator Amy Klobuchar
has dropped out of the running
citing an historic opportunity on race
to me this moment in time
cries out for putting someone of color
on that ticket with him and I really
believe it Biden's shortlist is believed
to include Warren as well as senators
and governors from swing states and in
addition to Kamala Harris other women of
color some not so well known are
emerging as serious candidates we don't
have another hour to wait the mayor of
Atlanta is under consideration as his
Florida congresswoman Val Demmings
though she's careful not to campaign for
the post I am absolutely honored to be
considered to run along side Joe Biden
and I'll leave it there
he continues to face tremendous pressure
to pick a woman of color but despite the
recent headlines Biden continues to
insist he's looking for someone he'd be
comfortable working with and who he
believes is qualified for the job
Biden's team has produced an ad that
emphasizes his priorities
wounds that have long plagued our
country Joe Biden is expected to make
his vice presidential pick by mid-summer
the contrast to Biden himself
generational gender and racial could
produce a presidential ticket that
better reflects all of America Eric
Sorenson Global News Toronto still ahead
how the pandemic has thrown a wrench
into a once-in-a-lifetime pilgrimage
there was disappointing but expected
news for millions of Muslims around the
world this week the government of Saudi
Arabia has banned any foreign travel
into the country for the annual Hajj
pilgrimage normally two million visitors
will visit the holy site of Mecca as
Redmond Shannon reports it's likely just
a few hundred Saudis will be permitted
to take part in this centuries-old
tradition it is one of the greatest
examples of mass worship on the planet
Hajj every Muslim who is healthy and can
afford to go is expected to do so once
in their life Khadija Farooq and Adil
Hassan from Edmonton had saved up for
two years to go this July deposits in
January and around March I think when
the NBA shut down was kind of lame I
don't think we're gonna be able to go
that realization was finally confirmed
this week by Saudi authorities it's
crushing it's crushing it's
disappointing - held regularly since the
Prophet Muhammad went to Mecca in the
seventh century it has been canceled or
heavily scaled back about 40 times over
the years for war politics and plagues
most recently for cholera outbreaks in
the nineteenth century but the decision
to allow a small number of local
pilgrims this year
make sure the unbroken tradition of Hajj
in modern times continues I think it's a
clever idea to run a small the
government would know who has been to
hospital and who has been infected and
who hasn't been and they can make sure
that everyone is tested before they
embark on the hunt spiritual preparation
is a major part of Hajj something that
now has to be put on hold
I think it's devastating for many people
it is gonna be really hard for many
people to take but I think from a
spiritual perspective and from a
life-saving perspective they understand
this has been done for health reasons
it's an outlook that pilgrims are
clinging to until a year comes when it's
safe to go again not going for hedges as
I think it form of worship it is itself
because the prophets teachings tell us
not to travel during a pandemic
when covered 19 is no longer a threat
the Saudi government could face a
logistical headache with a backlog of
millions of pilgrims all hoping to
finally make their way to Mecca Redmond
Shannon Global News London
up next when you gotta go ya gotta go
the rocket science to relieve astronauts
you might snicker at this next story but
for astronauts it's serious business
NASA hopes to return to the moon in 2024
but it has a million problems to sort
out before it happens one of them trying
to get a single toilet to work in outer
space as might relay reports it's a
problem that needs more than just rocket
science it takes a remarkable amount of
smarts to get to the moon obviously
right NASA has to think of everything
from the Rockets to the spacesuits the
food and of course how the astronauts go
to the bathroom for the Apollo missions
of the 1960s they used vacuum seal bags
which seems like an afterthought the way
we follow it just was not tenable to as
an astronaut to go through the the
Apollo bag scenario again part of the
transcript from that Apollo 10 mission
in 1969 reads I didn't do it in ain't
one of mine
followed by I don't think it's one of
mine and I'll leave it at that
so as NASA gears up for Artemis the
program to return to the moon in 2024
they're asking for help
there are three companies that are
competing to design the lunar lander and
now NASA through the Canadian
crowdsourcing startup hero X has
launched the lunar loot challenge the
amount of talent that exists in the
world is unfathomable almost but they're
underutilized you know we're still stuck
in an organizational mindset of a higher
team and we try to solve problems cliff
Edwards a Canadian who's 1/32 of the
over 100 challenges he's entered is
among the over 1200 inventors who signed
up in the first 24 hours it's NASA and
be it's it's about bathrooms toilets or
and those are very attractive to a lot
of people because it's like maybe we can
think of something even if we don't know
about space you know it's it's very open
kind of challenge but it won't be easy
the toilet has to work in the
microgravity we see on the space station
and then after a 20-hour journey from
orbit to the moon it has to convert to
lunar gravity which is 1/6 of what we
have on earth
there's suction involved or getting a
good seal with your butt on you know for
a Boeing number two so it's not just
sitting on a toilet and going there's
you know straps and harnesses yes
there's harnesses so giggle away nobody
likes to talk about this stuff but it's
a fact of life and NASA will do anything
it can to avoid another Apollo 10
incident we have these fundamental human
physiology this is this is an important
one my car like Global News Toronto it
is important and that is global national
for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is Komaki Ontario we would
love to see your part of the country so
email your pictures thank you for
watching Donna Friesen will be here
tomorrow good night
[Music]